this is extreme weather
and we're going to be seeing much more
of it
how ready are you
global warming is going to cause
different types of extreme weather
in different places the the changes seen
globally
um to climate change are going to vary
quite widely some places may get drier
some places may get wetter by increasing
the
level of greenhouse gases in the
atmosphere we are effectively
putting an extra blanket to further warm
the earth
and that is disrupting the sort of
delicate balance of the
earth system because we have a warmer
atmosphere it is able to
hold more water which therefore
translates into more rainfall too
in fact some research suggests that for
every one degree of warming
we're going to get between 5 and 10
percent more rainfall
the flooding that we've seen in germany
in belgium you know the the
cause of that was a slow-moving storm
there was some research that showed that
it looked like they were going to be 14
times more likely by the end of the
century
places like bangladesh have been dealing
with increasingly deadly floods
for years
but many countries continue to be
surprised by extreme weather like heat
waves floods or fires there are still
things we can do to slow down climate
change
we have to wake up to the track we are
on globally and a very real possibility
that climate change will force tens if
not hundreds of millions of people to
have to leave their homes in the future
but we also need to learn to live with
some of the consequences
that are already here
that's a concept called climate
adaptation
[Music]
we've spoken to the experts on how to
adapt to extreme weather in the future
we have had floods we've had iceborns
this is mississauga a city in canada
that has growing problems with extreme
weather
significant wind storms which of course
takes down trees
we've had extreme heat the city declared
a climate emergency
and has created a 450 million dollar
climate action plan
we estimate the cost to be about half a
billion dollars to
over the next decade alone but one
severe ice storm
could range from 23 million to 38
million
although they're going to reduce their
environmental impact
diane's team are also completely
reorganizing mississauga
to deal with the parts of climate change
that are already here
we have 62 stormwater management ponds
in the city of mississauga now
and what these ponds do is to help us
control storm water quality
and water quantity we're on the shores
of lake ontario and we have a number of
lakeside parks that absorb the water
into the ground
over 40 000 trees shrubs wildflowers and
grasses
are planted annually we are wanting to
plant one million trees
across the city so that again it absorbs
the water
[Music]
measures like roof drainage control
permeable
pavement stormwater ponds here what
you're seeing is the energy dissipator
which is the outlet of the stormwater
management pod
i think the key message is just really
applying a climate lens to decision
making
and leadership i think that you know we
can't do this without strong leadership
we have to you know arm our our
leadership with
with the right science with the right
solutions to advance and and protect our
not just our own residents but our
neighbors are around us
and for us individuals there are ways
you can prepare for extreme weather
yourself
[Music]
the scouts have it right always be
prepared